[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ce nouveau numéro du sky
échos le magazine qui vous raconte les
aventures économique du territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines et me voilà
devant un stock de déchets plastiques
des déchets plastiques parce que nous
allons plonger dans le monde de
l'économie circulaire la spécialité de
la start-up plaisir oise recorec créé en
2018 elle utilise ces déchets plastique
pour fabriquer un matériau innovant un
matériau innovant qui permet ensuite de
concevoir du mobilier ou des
infrastructures elle est actuellement en
phase d'industrialisation à travers une
levée de fonds c'est au programme de ce
39e numéro du sky est courte le sprint
cup se tient du 31 mai au 10 juin 2022
dix jours pour découvrir les métiers du
numérique
une initiative sur le modèle du summer
kang qui s'est tenue en 2020 la start up
les iroise grecs ne règle poursuit son
développement spécialisée dans la
réutilisation des déchets plastiques
elle va s'agrandir pour entrer dans une
phase d'industrialisation
c'est une pme créée en 1921 basée à
montigny le bretonneux l'entreprise
kohler s'est transmise sur quelle
génération dans la famille
[Musique]
et on commence cette émission avec le
sprint cup qui se déroulera du 31 mai au
10 juin 10 jours d'initiation aux
métiers du numérique le sprint comme
c'est la version printanière du summer
camps qui s'étaient déroulées en 2020
rappelez vous
[Musique]
j'ai appris en fait que la sécurité
s'était pas que du script etc il y avait
aussi pas mal de décryptage
[Musique]
cette initiative participe de cette
prise en main du numérique et des
métiers encore une fois des opportunités
économiques des opportunités d'emploi
qui sont derrière
[Musique]
et si vous êtes intéressés par cette
initiation aux métiers du numérique
n'hésitez pas à vous inscrire sur le
site internet qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran
[Musique]
vous
et nous sommes dans l'atelier de rec
n'aurait que c'est ici qu'est fabriqué
ce matériau innovant à partir des
déchets plastiques que vous voyez juste
derrière moi et pour en parler nous
sommes avec la fondatrice de rec nord
avec hugo line solaire bonjour bonjour
nicolas
alors est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
comment on arrive à fabriquer sa à
partir de sa famille oui et bien en fait
c'est un processus de don je vais pas
détailler tous les toutes les étapes
parce qu'il ya une grosse étape de
conduire confidentialité en raison du
caractère très innovant est relativement
simple finalement de notre solution
puisque on s'inscrit dans la logique à
des fins de minimiser les coûts de
simplifier la maintenance est
globalement d'être dans un processus
très facilement déployable dans de
nombreux territoires donc c'est un
processus qui passe évidemment par une
étape de broyage des déchets plastiques
pour en faire des miettes sans lavage et
sans tri préalable ensuite ces miettes
en les associés entre elles pour obtenir
les bonnes propriétés du matériau afin
d'obtenir les planches que vous avez
montré par un processus globalement de
2 types thermomécanique on travaille la
température des plastiques et on les
malaxe de façon à arriver à un produit
qui va pouvoir prendre la forme qu'on
lui donne soit de planchette soit comme
le font beaucoup des profils et nous
aussi ici on va on va développer un
procédé particulier qu'il va aller vers
du format plan de la planche pour
ceux destinés à être utilisés à la place
de planches de bois traditionnels
actuellement vous êtes en pleine levée
de fonds une levée de fonds qui va
servir à quoi finalement alors cette
levée de fonds bien là ici on peut pas
tout vous montrer mais on est dans un
espace qui est très petit on a 75 m² on
est vraiment à l'étroit il ya beaucoup
de déchet parce qu'on travaille sur
beaucoup de matériaux différents et est
ce qu'on a besoin maintenant c'est de
faire notre preuve à une échelle
industrielle certes encore à une échelle
a relativement réduite on va commencer
par 300 puis mille tonnes par an donc
c'est un bref changement par rapport à
ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui et pour ça il
faut des machines il faut un local il
faut une organisation complète qui
nécessite évidemment des fonds et c'est
cette levée de fond qu'on a qu'on a
engagés sur la plateforme guido good
parce que répondrai que c'est un projet
citoyen qui dès le départ a été
soutenu à fond par les citoyens qu'ils
soient de plaisir saint quentin ou même
de france et de fait on souhaite que la
valeur ajoutée portée alors ajouté
financière bien sûr apporté par le
produit et toute cette démarche bas soit
plutôt partagés avec les citoyens donc
on leur propose de parthenay participer
à cette levée de fonds et si vous
souhaitez participer à l'aventuré cno
rec le site internet pour participer à
cette levée de fonds s'affiche en bas de
l'écran reste noir il sait combien de
personnes aujourd'hui on retrouve quel
type de profil alors aujourd'hui on est
une équipe de 14 personnes réparties au
niveau statut entre des stagiaires des
alternants et d'aidé permanent bien sûr
on est on va dire une un tiers des
équipes techniques recherche et
développement et production un tiers des
équipes commerciales et communication et
un petit tiers équipes administratives
et et direction on essaye d'avoir un peu
tous les métiers et on a une équipe très
jeune et très dynamique et puis avec
n'aurait que c'est pas seulement l'inter
ne s'est aussi l'externe puisque vous
travaillez aussi avec des partenaires et
on a rencontré justement le menuisier
mathieu lafon basée à plaisir ils
travaillent avec vous ils travaillent
sur votre matériaux regardez bonjour je
m'appelle mathieu lafon je suis artisan
menuisier plasturgiste vazia plaisir je
travaille le bois les matières
plastiques
je travaille en relation avec rec norrec
qui m'a apporté des matières plastiques
justement à retravailler donc j'ai
beaucoup de découpe nous avons un projet
sont des bancs pour les collectivités là
je fais des couples pour des petits
mouchoirs
c'est intéressant parce que c'est une
autre façon de travailler c'est encore
des techniques un petit peu différente
comme c'est un mélange de matières
plastiques
il y à d'autres précautions à prendre
par la même vitesse forcément les mêmes
outils l'idée c'est de participer un
petit peu à petite échelle que le serbe
est sérieux que je connais pas très bien
pour pouvoir faire des gros chiffrage
des choses comme ça pour l'instant on
travaille en collaboration puis un jour
on mettra un prix dessus ça ça sera
beaucoup plus facile ce que j'ai déjà
fait pour restaurer qui ce sont des
prototypes de porte documents
réglable il y avait un petit peu de
métal pas beaucoup leurs matériaux
plastiques on a fait deux essais de
découpe décès de rabotage pour voir
comment rendez le matériau avec des
aspects de surface différente
pour les ben moi je vais être sur la
partie travail de la matière de drake
noël donc je vais leur faire leur
découpe pour en faire des lames elle
même assemblée et à fixer sur des
structures en a six
toujours en compagnie d'hugo line
solaire dirigeante de rec n'aurait que
nous avons rejoint les bureaux de la
start-up juste à côté de l'atelier alors
nous voulons le voir vous avez un
partenariat avec le menuisier mathieu
lafon c'est un plaisir oit comment vous
avez fait ce compact en fait l'année
dernière on avait un alternant qui
avaient comme mission de faire le tour
des partenaires locaux en menuiserie en
métallerie qui pouvait nous aider à
concrétiser la réalisation des objets
qu'on commercialise et donc il a
rencontré mathieu lafon qui s'est montré
très motivés par ce projet qui prend
encore plus de sens du fait de son de
son installation un plaisir donc on est
d'ailleurs en recherche permanente de
partenaires nouveau pour transformer des
coupes et aménager créer des objets
histoire de répondre à des demandes de
produits plus ou moins originaux ou du
prototype ou des who de la série donc le
type de profession comme parce que là on
parle d'un menuisier mais pour chercher
quels types de partenaires cherchent des
métalliers des aménageurs paysagiste qui
pourrait créer des aménagements
extérieurs on cherche oui évidemment des
menuisiers des gens qui sont spécialisé
dans la découpe aussi puisque nous notre
vocation n'est pas de créer tout ça en
interne mais de le faire avec des
partenaires
spécialisée et donc voilà toute activité
qui peut être amenée à travailler le
bois des fabricants d'objets en grande
série pour le jardin pour la maison on
étudie tout ça parce qu'on a beaucoup de
demandes très diverses en fait alors on
vient de découvrir ce que vous faites
dans l'atelier la conception du matériau
là on l'a matériaux directement produit
qu'est ce qu'on peut en faire ensuite on
voit différents objets autour de nous là
on peut faire beaucoup de choses avec ce
matériau oui on peut faire beaucoup de
choses mais en fait il est assez simple
c'est se projeter dans l'utilisation
habituelle du bois donc le bois pas
uniquement sous forme de l'âme comme
pour des terrasses mais de la planche de
bois qui va être transformée dans toutes
sortes
d'aménagement que ce soit donc je le
disais tout à l'heure du mobilier que ce
soit des créations plus complète là on a
un catalogue qu'on a qu'on a édité qui
donne des inspirations sur ce qu'on peut
être amené à faire alors ça va
d'équipements qui vont aller dans les
milieux naturels pour aménager ces
espaces la sava à du mobilier comme on a
ici
notre gamme notre gamme modulaire est le
projet qui est en train de se finaliser
c'est l'installation de gradins donc
c'est plutôt un habillage de gradins en
béton qui vont être couvert avec notre
matériau pour un effet de confort et un
effet esthétique vraiment joyeux
puisqu'on a design est un matériau
exprès pour dans quelques établissements
c'est au collège apollinaire à plaisir
et donc là on voit aussi des débats en
finalement on peut tout faire avec votre
matériaux parce qu' ils ont peut le
travailler comme vous l'avez dit que
comme du bois exactement le travail à
l'ucl de même outillage évidemment il
faut pour tenir compte de sa dureté et
donc adapter les équipements de découpe
mais c'est le même c'est le même sillage
c'est le même type de contraintes on va
pas aller vers de l'astra de la
charpente et de la structure pour le
moment c'est pas du tout la destination
de notre matériau mais vraiment tout ce
qui va être habillée création de
mobilier ou qu'est ce que vous avez à
god hand ball par exemple alors là vous
avez un
design de composteur rotatif on a un
système d'ouverture qui qui permet de
très facilement la liberté mais qui
permet aussi très facilement de le vider
je vais passer de l'autre côté parce que
normalement on imagine une brouette qui
vient récupérer le compost est donc pas
besoin de se baisser et plus besoin de
se faire mal au dos pour récupérer ce
produit qui se retrouve très très
facilement
mélangez on l'a dit tout à l'heure on a
reparlé de cette levée de fonds qui va
être stratégique pour vous parce que ça
vous permettent d'industrialiser
votre matériel ça va pouvoir de multi
multiplier la production de votre
matériel d'ailleurs le site internet
s'affiche en bas de l'écran si vous êtes
intéressés pour participer à l'aventuré
snorek quels sont les défis après cette
levée de fonds dereck norrec alors les
défis c'est comme pour n'importe quelle
activité de production d'un produit
innovant c'est le cas de notre matériau
basse et de le commercialiser
suffisamment pour pouvoir aspirer j'aime
bien cette image d'aller aspirer les
déchets plastiques et donc pouvoir
traiter un maximum de ces déchets et
dépolluer au maximum donc nous ce qu'on
recherche aujourd'hui c'est à construire
des collaborations avec des entreprises
ou des consommateurs finaux que ce soit
des collectivités des entreprises ou ou
des particuliers pour qu'ils s'habituent
à utiliser ce matériau dans leur
aménagement courant et qu'ils soient
demandeurs de cette consommation de
déchets au travers de ses planches et
bien merci hugo line solaire merci
beaucoup je rappelle dirigeante et
fondatrice de rec norrec et le sky échos
se poursuit à plaisir chérèque norrec
[Musique]
découverte maintenant d'une entreprise
familiale l'entreprise colère a été
créée en
1921 elle est spécialisé dans le
prototypage notamment dans le domaine de
l'industrie
aujourd'hui elle est basée à montigny le
bretonneux et elle tend à se diversifier
rencontre avec romain kohler c'est
l'arrière petit fils du fondateur de
cette entreprise
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je m'appelle romain colère je dirige
l'entreprise colère située à montils
bretonneux notre entreprise a été créée
en 1921 par mes arrière-grands-parents
puis transmis de génération en
génération
[Musique]
je colère nous sommes environ une
vingtaine de personnes au fil de toutes
ces années les métiers ont évolué à ce
jour nous fabriquons avec la filière
numérique plutôt physique
les produits de nos clients dans le
l'automobile dans l'aéronautique le
nautisme et le ferroviaire
[Musique]
notre activité principale c'est
effectivement de la r&d c'est à dire que
nous modélisons des formes pour nos
clients donc la recherche de formes mais
pas seulement depuis quelques années on
se diversifie dans d'autres domaines
notamment nous inonder des pièces en
carbone pour nos clients notre vraie
valeur ajoutée c'est d'être une pme avec
les moyens d'un grand groupe c'est à
dire que nous avons du matériel de haute
technicité de pointe
[Musique]
on essaie de rester à notre taille et
bien performant en investissant pour
être à la pointe de ce qui se fait en
termes de matériel notre stratégie sera
plutôt de diversifier notre panel
clients mais c'est à dire que à une
époque on était très automobile on s'est
diversifié dans le nautisme puis dans
l'aéronautique et dans d'autres domaines
à ces divers c'est la fin de ce numéro
chérèque norrec merci de l'avoir suivi
une émission que vous pouvez revoir en
replay sur notre site internet ou sur
l'application mobile à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]